Learn how to build a platformer game in Python.
This game will have collisions, gravity, animated characters, and much much more!
Tim with Tech with Tim teaches this course. Tim has one of the most subscribed software channels on YouTube.
In this video, I'll be sharing with you
how to build a platformer game in Python.
This game will have pixel
perfect collision.
It will have an animated character,
as you can see here.
It will have single and double jumping.
It will have all kinds of different
animations for falling, jumping,
colliding with obstacles.
For example, you can see here, when I hit the fire, I kind of go into this hit state.
I will show you how to generate different
objects, how to scroll the background. And really, at the end of this video,
you will have a solid, fundamental
understanding of how to build
a platformer game in Python.
And you can go and extend this and build
really anything that you can think of.
I will even include a ton of free assets for you
that allow you to change your character,
change the terrain, change the background,
and do all of that extremely easily.
In fact in this tutorial alone, I will show you how to use
four different characters.
Let me show you those characters
before we continue.
So this is the second character here. This is being referred to as mask dude.
This is the third character. I'm calling this guy
the ninja frog, as you can see.
And finally, we have this character here,
which is called Pinkman.
Now in this tutorial, you will learn
how to use all of these characters
and you can swap them out
with a single line of code.
All right. So let's
go ahead and get into it now.
Since this is a long video,
I do want to spend a minute here
just talking about who
this video is designed for
exactly what you're going to learn
and what you can expect to see.
Don't waste your time
if you don't want to go through it.
So this video is really designed
for people that have a bit of experience
with Python.
Ideally, you are an intermediate
or a Python programmer.
You understand the syntax,
you know, for loops, you know, functions,
you know all of that.
If you don't feel free to follow along.
But I'm not going to be explaining
those basic concepts.
Now, this video will teach you
how to build exactly what you see here.
So by the end of the video
you will have exactly this.
And if you're not interested in waiting
until the end of the video,
then you can download the code
from the GitHub repository
that I will leave in the description.
That's also
where all the assets are going to be.
So regardless, you're going to have
to download the code from GitHub.
Again, I will leave that description,
download that,
open up the folder and kind of
we could start working from there.
Now really what I'm going to be showing
you here mostly is sprite sheet animation,
pixel perfect collision using
what's called masks,
and then how you can do
the scrolling background
generating objects,
all of that kind of stuff.
That is really the hard part when it comes
to generating a platformer game.
Once you have all of that down, it's
very easy to extend this, to add levels,
to add like, you know, a finishing flag,
to add coins, to add, you know, lives.
You can turn this game
into anything you want.
And that's how I've designed this, is
that you have the base and then you can go
and make it kind of a full fledged game
and work off of that.
So that said, I will stop talking now.
I think this game looks really good.
I'm excited to share this with you guys.
So let's get into actually building it.
So right now
I have Visual Studio code open.
Obviously we're doing this in Python
and I already have high game install.
Now the first thing we're going to have to
do is install PI game, which is the module
we're going to be using.
So to do that, go to your terminal
and type pip install PI game.
If that doesn't work for you, you're
going to try pip three install PI game.
If that doesn't work,
try python hyphen m pip instal pi game.
If that doesn't work, try python three
hyphen m pip install pi game.
If none of those work, I'll leave
two videos on the screen
that show you how to install that module.
Now, once you have PI game installed,
I'm going to assume that you've downloaded
the GitHub repository.
Go to GitHub.
There's a little button that says Click
to download, download the folder extracted
to your desktop and then open it
in this code or whatever editor you want.
So you have something that looks like
this.
You should have an assets directory
inside of assets, you should have a bunch
of different folders.
Then you should have a main python file
that contains all of the finished code.
Now obviously
we're going
to write the code from scratch, but
you can either work off that existing code
or you can kind of clear the file
and type along with me,
whatever you want to do.
I quickly want to run through the assets
folder and then we'll get into the code.
So in assets we have a ton of stuff.
We're not going to use most of this,
but I wanted to include all of it
so that you could kind of continue
the game later if you want.
So we have, for example, backgrounds.
These are a bunch of background tiles,
so you can change kind of the theme
or color of the background very easily.
I'll show you how to do that.
We have items like boxes,
checkpoints, fruits, etc.
We're not going to use any of those.
Then we have main characters.
For main characters,
we have a bunch of sprite sheets
inside of here and I'll show you how
we can split these sprite sheets apart
and use all of the different
kind of animations inside of your right.
So we have that for my stud
ninja frog, Pink Men and Virtual Guy.
All of the file names are the exact same.
Okay, then we have menu.
We're not going to be using anything
from there.
We have other, we have terrain.
We are actually going to be using terrain
specifically.
We're going to pull out
this kind of block here.
But you could change the block again
if you want to do that.
And then we have traps
and we are going to be
using the fire trap,
wherever that is right here
that has kind of an animation right
where the fires go.
But again,
you can add all of this stuff later on.
I'll show
you kind of the based on how to do it and
then you'll be able to extend from there.
Okay.
Now that we understand the assets,
I apologize for such a long introduction.
Let's get into writing the code.
I also need to plug the idea of the course
programing expert.
So if you guys want to get better
at Python,
check that out from the link
in the description.
Okay. So let's start at the top.
Our program here.
By importing everything we need, we're
going to import LS, we're going to import
random, we're going to import
math, we're going to import PY game.
We're going to say from OS import
list directory
and we're going to say from OS stop path
import is file and join.
Now the reason I'm doing all this OS stuff
is because we are going to be dynamically
loading all of the sprite sheets
and the images
so we don't have to manually like type
out the file names that we want.
I'll show you how we write a function
that just loads
these folders here, kind of splits
the sprite sheets automatically
and gives us all of the images
that we're interested in.
Okay.
After we do that,
we're going to say py game dot net,
we need to initialize the py game module.
Then we're going to go down here, we're
going to set a caption for a display.
I'm going to say py game
dot display dot set underscore caption.
If you're unfamiliar
with what this is doing,
the setting the caption
at the top of the window,
I'll try to explain most the PY game stuff
as we go through the video.
I also have a ton of videos
umpire game on my channel
if you want to check out something
a little bit more basic.
Okay.
Now what I'm going to do
is define a few global variables
that we're going to be using here.
The first one is going to be
the background color.
Now we'll use this for now
until we implement our own background.
And for the background color,
I'm going to make this white,
which is going to be 255 to 50
5 to 55, all of our colors
and py game are going to be in rg.
B Okay, so red, green, blue, that's
what we have for our background color.
We're going to define the width
and the height of our screen.
For some of you,
you're going to have to make this smaller
if you're on a smaller display.
For me, I'm on a2k monitor,
so I'm going to go with a thousand by 800.
But if you're on again a smaller screen,
you might want to make this
just a bit smaller
so that it works for you,
although it doesn't really matter.
Make it whatever size you want.
Next I'm going to say my focus,
which is my frames
per second, is going to be equal to 60
and I'm going to define my player
velocity equal to five.
And this is going to be the speed at which
my player moves around the screen.
Okay.
Now that we've done that,
we need to set up a game window.
So I'm going to say PI game,
dot display, dot set underscore mode,
and I'm going to pass the width
and the height
to this window argument
here, this mode argument.
And this is going to kind of create
the PI game window for us.
I'm going to store that
in the window variable and there we go.
We have kind of our global variables
created.
Now I'm going to make a main function
and I say to find main,
this main function is going to be
what we run to kind of start the game.
So inside of here, I'm
going to take a window and at the bottom
my program, I'm going to say if
underscore, underscore, name, underscore,
underscore is equal to underscore,
underscore, main, underscore, underscore,
then call the main function
and pass the window argument.
Okay?
So hopefully you can see kind
of the structure of our program already.
The reason I have this line right here
is so that we only call the main function.
If we run this file directly,
if we don't run this file directly,
say we imported something from it,
then we won't run the game code.
Okay.
So that's why I have this inside of
Main is where we're going to write
kind of our event loop.
The event loop will be what's handling,
say, the collision and moving
our character, redrawing the window,
all of that kind of stuff.
This kind of good practice
to have your event loop in one place.
So inside of the main function,
we need to set up a few things.
The first thing we need is a clock.
So we're going to say clock is equal
to pi game time, dart clock.
We also need to define what is it a while
loop that's going to continually loop
and act as our event loop.
So I'm going to say run is equal to true.
I'm going to say wild, true
or well run string
and then the first thing I'm going to do
is say clocked tick.
Yes. Now FIPS members are variable right
here.
What this line does
is ensures that our while loop
is going to run 60 frames per second.
Okay, so no more than 60 times per second.
That's what this ensures.
If you're on a really slow
computer, chances are you could be running
less than 60 frames per second.
But in my case,
I'm on quite a fast computer,
and if I didn't put this year,
then you'd see that my game
would be like way faster than yours.
So we need to do this to regulate
the frame rate across different devices.
Okay, now that we have that,
we're going to say for event
in game dot, event docket
and the first event that we're going to
check for is if the user quits the game.
If they quit by quitting, I mean they hit
the red ax in the top right hand corner.
Then we need to stop the event loop
and exit our program.
So I'm going to say if event type
is equal to per game, don't quit.
Then we're going to say run
is equal
to false
and we can break out of this loop.
Then we can go down here
and we can say hi game talk, quit notice.
This is outside of the wall loop
and then we can put quit, which
will actually quit the Python program.
Okay, so now we have our basic event loop
and what should happen if I run the code
now is a plug in window should pop up.
Nothing should be on the screen.
And if I hit the red arrow,
it should close.
So let's try this and see what we get.
K Notice it says platformer
and then I hit X and it closes.
Perfect.
We're well on our way
to creating the platformer game.
All right,
so now that we've done that,
I actually think that
the first thing we can do
is generate our background.
Then once we have the background,
we can create a basic player
that we can move around the screen.
And once we have that,
we'll start doing all of the animations.
And then later in the video, once
we've got kind of the bulk of the stuff
done, we'll handle the collision
and all of the movements.
Right? Okay.
So I need to make a function here
and I'm going to call
this get underscore background.
Now before I dove into this, let's
have a look at our assets folder again.
Now, what I want to do
is use these tiles, right?
They're just tiles.
I believe they're sizes 64 by 64,
32 by 32, something along those lines
anyways, we want to use these tiles
and tile, the whole background.
So what I need to do is essentially create
a whole grid of these tiles
based on the size of my screen.
So the way I'm going to do
that is by using a folder here.
This folder is going to return to me.
So not this folder,
right about this function.
This function is going to return to me
a list that contains
all of the background tiles
that we need to draw.
So that's we're going to do here
with get background.
Now what we want to take
is the name sorry.
As I was saying,
the name is going to be
the color of our background
and that's going to allow us to change
what background that we're using.
So the first thing we need to do
here is load this background image.
Now it's very important
that when you run this file,
you run it from the directory
that the file exists.
Now, the reason I'm saying that right now
is because the way I'm going to load
this image relies on the fact
that you're running this code
from the directory that it exists in.
So see here
that I'm in desktop Python platformer
and then notice tutorials
inside of that directory.
That's why this is going to work
if you try to run this code
from a different
directory, says see the desktop
and then I tried to run this,
then I'm going to get an issue.
So just make sure you're
in the correct directory.
I just want to say that
before we even get into this.
Okay, so I'm going to load my image
and the image
is equal to py game dot image, dot load.
And then what I'm going to do
is join the assets path
which is directly in the directory
this files in with the background
path here, if I spell background correctly
and then with the name
which is going to be the file
name that I want to load,
which is really
just the color of the background.
Okay.
Now that I have that, I want to get
the width and the height of this image.
So I'm not guessing what it is.
So I'm going to say
underscore, underscore width.
Height is equal
to image.
Don't get underscore rect.
Now when you do this,
it will give you the x y width, height.
I don't care about the x y.
So I've just put two underscores here
denoting
noting
that I don't care about these values
and then I'm able to grab the width
and height.
So now that I have the width
in the height, I'm going to say tiles
is equal to an empty list
and then I'm going to loop through
essentially how many tiles I need
to create in the X and the Y direction.
So going to say four, I'm in range
and then I'm going to take my width,
I'm going to integer,
divide this by the width of my tile
and I'm going to add one
and I'm going to do the same thing
for my height here.
So I say four Jain range height
over the height of my image plus one.
Okay, so notice width
here is the width of the screen.
Height is the height of the screen.
I'm integer
dividing this by the width of my tile
and that tells me approximately
how many tiles I need
kind of in the x direction
to fill the whole screen.
Then just to make sure
that I don't have any gaps, I add one
and I do the exact same thing for height
in the y direction.
Then what I'm going to do is say,
actually, yeah, I'm going to say rect
is this rect snow where I say
pause is equal to
I multiplied by the width and j
multiplied by the height.
And this is going to denote the position
of the top left hand
corner of the current tile that I'm adding
to this Tiles list in PI game.
When you draw something on the screen,
you draw it from the top left hand corner.
So what I'll be doing
is continually moving the positions
based on
how this for loop is going, right?
So for every I, for every j
and multiplying it by the width
and multiplying it by the height,
and that gives me the accurate position.
I need to place
every single tile in on the screen.
Hopefully that makes a bit of sense,
but that's how this is working.
And then I'm going to set to start
append my position
and then I'm going to return my tiles.
I'm also going to return the image
so that I can know
what image I need to use
when I'm drawing all of these tiles.
Okay.
Now that I have my background,
I'm going to go into main,
I'm going to say
my background is equal to get background.
And for the name I'm going to reference
here in the background
folder any of these images
so we can use anyone we want.
I don't really matter.
I kind of like the blue one,
so I'll go with blue.
Feel free to change
this though on your end. And
there we go, if I can type this correctly.
Okay. So going to say background comma,
BGP, image like that.
And now I want to set up something
that's going to draw my background.
So I'm going to make a function here
and I'm going to say draw.
This is going to take in a window and
for now it's going to take in a background
and later it'll take in everything else
you want to draw inside of here.
I say plugin, dot display, dot update.
And before I do that, I'm
going to draw my background.
So I'm going to say four
and this is going to be tile
in background like that.
And then I'm going to say window doublets
and actually
I need to take my BG image as well.
So let's take that
and I'm
going to draw the background image.
And then what I need to pass
here is the position I want to draw it at,
which is going to be tile.
So what I can actually do
is just convert this to a tuple.
Notice
the tile is going to be a list, right?
Tile is going to contain
kind of my X-Y position.
You can see that here. Right?
We're appending pause,
which is a list of x, Y,
and now that I think of it,
so make it easier.
Let's just make this a tuple directly
and now we don't need to convert it.
Okay.
So in case anyone's confused,
what we're doing here is looping through
every single tile that we have,
and then we're going to draw
our background image at that position,
which will fill the entire screen
with background images.
Then what we're going to do
is update the display,
the reason we update it so that every
single frame we kind of clear the screen.
Right.
And we don't have old drawings
still on the screen.
You'll see what I mean in a second.
But this draw function is where
we're going to do all of our drawing.
For now, the only thing we need to draw
is the background.
Later it will be the player,
the blocks, the obstacles, etc.
okay, so
now I'm going to go inside of my wallet.
I'm going to call this draw function
that we just created.
I'm going to pass window
and then of course,
I'm going to pass my background
and my BG image.
Okay.
Now this reminds me that I no longer need
this background color.
We're not going to use that
so I can get rid of that there.
Okay.
So at this point,
assuming I've loaded the image correctly,
we're now going to see this
tiling the entire screen.
So let's save and run and notice
that we get it right.
Styling
the entire screen looks pretty good to me
and we can quite easily change this
if we want by just going here
and saying okay, rather than blue,
I want yellow.
And we say yellow
and now we get a yellow background.
Great.
So that's kind of the advantage
of how I've done this here.
You can change the background to any color
you want.
Well,
given that's in the background directory,
now that we have our background,
what should we do next?
Well, we probably want to put a player
on the screen and start
seeing some images for that player.
Now, the player itself is the most
complicated aspect of this program.
There's a lot of movement
going on with it.
So we'll start by
just creating like a block for our player,
kind of move
the block around, have a jumping around.
Then once we do that,
we'll do all of the sprites and animations
just so that we can get some more progress
before we dove into that
because it is a bit of work.
Okay, so let's go
here and let's say class player,
we're going to use a class for our player.
It kind of makes sense here.
And this class is going to inherit
from page game,
dot sprite, dot sprite.
Now I don't typically use sprites
when I'm working in pie game,
but I'm going to use them
in this tutorial.
And the reason for that is that
it makes it very easy to do pixel perfect
collision when we have two sprite objects
which we're going to have
because we're inheriting from the pie game
sprite class, we can use a method
that tells us if the sprites
are colliding with each other.
So just understand, that's
why I'm doing this inheritance.
You don't have to understand
exactly what the Sprite is,
but it kind of denotes
that we have some properties on our class
and then it allows
these special paging methods
to use those properties
to handle the collision for us
so we don't have to write anything
too complicated
when it comes to the collision,
although we still do
need to handle it a bit.
Okay, so what we're going to do here
is define our initialization area,
taking a self, an x, y, width and height.
Now the width and height
will really be determined by the image
that we're using for our player.
But for now, since we're going to have
like a block for our player,
and so we add that image,
we're going to have a width and height.
Now that reminds me that I just need
to set a color for my player.
So I'm going to say color is 250 500.
I'm making this a class variable
just so it's the same for
all of my players and I have access to it
just right on the class.
Okay.
Now what I'm going to do is say self-doubt
racked is equal to pi game dot rect
and then pass my x y width and height.
So rather than representing
all of these values individually,
we're just going to put them
on the rectangle.
And this is going to make it
a little bit easier for us to kind of move
the player around and do collision
and all of that.
So really, it's just a couple that's
storing for individual values.
When I make it party game direct,
it means we can use it
in some kind of special equations
and whatnot.
Okay, now for our player,
we're going to have to have a few values.
The first thing we're going to have, I'm
getting a bit ahead of myself here,
but is going to be the x velocity and
the next is going to be the Y velocity.
Now the x and
y velocity is going to denote
what we call it
here, how fast we are moving our player.
Every single frame in both directions.
Right.
So the way the will actually move
our player
is we'll just apply a velocity
in a direction and then it'll just
keep moving in that direction
until we remove that velocity.
Now this will be great, for example,
for something like gravity or jumping,
and you'll see what I mean in a minute.
Okay. Now, do we have that?
We need to add something known as a mask.
For now, I'm
going to say the mask is equal to none.
And then I think that's
all we need for right now.
So now that we have
that, let's add our first function here,
which is going to be the move function.
So MOVE is going to take in a displacement
in the X direction
and a displacement in the Y direction.
And it's going to say the self direct X
plus equals
the direction x or displacement
x, sorry and self director y
plus equals the displacement y.
Now if we want to move up
or down or left or right, we just change
the sign of this d x or d y right?
Okay. So now we have move next.
What we want to do is create
two functions, one for moving to the left.
And this is going to take in the velocity
you want to move in the left direction
and the next is going to be moving
in the right direction.
Again, this is going to take in self
and vel now to move left.
What we're going to do
is say R self-taught x velocity
is equal to and then
this is going to be negative velocity.
And then to move to the right, we're going
to say self that exfil is equal to VEL.
Now the reason we use negative velocity
here is because if we want to go left,
we have to subtract from our exposition
in PI game.
Remember our coordinate system
is that zero zero is the top left
hand corner of the screen.
So if I want to move down
I add to my y coordinate.
And if I want to move to the right,
I add to my x coordinates.
If I want to go up, I subtract y.
If I want to go left, I subtract x.
So that's why
I'm putting a negative value here.
I know it seems a bit weird
how I've just done move
and now I'm saying move left here
and I have negative.
Don't worry,
you'll see how this works in a second.
Next I'm going to say if self
direction does not
equal left, then self-taught
direction is equal to left.
And I'm going to say self-taught animation
count is equal to zero.
Now, we're not going to use these
right now, but I just want to add them in
for now at least,
and you'll see why in a second.
Now, I'm also going to say up here,
self-taught direction is equal to left.
And the reason I'm adding this direction
is because I need to keep track of what
direction my player's facing.
So later, once I have my sprites, I know
if I'm showing the animation to the left
or I'm showing the animation to the right
now, the animation count.
I were resetting that
when we change directions.
And the reason we're doing
that is so that the animation doesn't look
all wonky when we go from going
left to right, we need to kind of reset
the count that we're using to change
the animation frames.
Again, you're going to see that later
as we go through the tutorial.
Now I've just added up here.
Softer animation can equal zero
just to make sure we don't get any weird
errors later.
So now I have my direction. I'm animation.
Perfect.
Okay, now I'm going to copy this.
I'm going to put the same thing
in move right.
And I'm going to change the
direction here to say right
and then right.
So now we know what direction
we're facing at all points in time.
Okay, perfect.
Next, what we need to do is we need to
have some kind of draw function.
And we also need to have
what I'm going to call the loop function.
And in fact,
let's do the loop function first.
So I'm going to say, fine loop.
And inside of here
I'm going to take in self and focus.
Now what loop is going to do
is be called once every frame.
When I say frame, that's
really one iteration of the while loop.
And this is going to move our character
in the correct direction
and handle things
like updating the animation and
all of the stuff that we constantly need
to do for our character.
So for right now, I only care about moving
in the right direction.
We'll handle the jumping later.
So what I'm going to do
is just say self, don't move.
And I'm going to say
that we're going to move
based on our x velocity
and our Y velocity.
Now notice
we're updating our x velocity here
when we move left or we move to the right.
So now if we call loop
and we have some velocity in the
X direction is going to move our character
to the left or to the right.
Okay.
Again, all this will start to make sense
as we get through the tutorial.
There is a lot of stuff
I need to do kind of upfront before
I can just show you instantly.
So hopefully you guys are following along.
But I just want to note we eventually
of course will see how all of this works.
I'll walk through the code, so no worries
if it's a bit confusing right now.
Now what else do we need to do
inside of loop?
Well, we need to update something
known as The Mask,
which I'm going to get to in a second.
But before we can do that, we need to
define what's known as our image.
So I'm going to say define
and this is going to be draw
and this is going to be the function
that handles drawing on the screen.
And for draw,
we are going to take in our window,
which I'll just represent with Will.
Now what we'll do for now
is we'll just say Pi, game,
dot, draw, dot, rectangle
will draw the rectangle on the window,
which is the first argument here.
It's where we're drawing it.
The second argument is the color
which is going to be self-taught color.
Then the last is directing.
So I'm going to say
that is self-taught self-correct.
Now notice the rect here, right?
Has our x y with height
and when we move we're updating the x
and y of the rectangle, which will then
change where we're drawing it.
If I can find it here on the screen.
Okay, so that's what we need for drawing
now, actually, for now,
I think that's okay.
We will add to this obviously in a second,
but I think we can generate a player,
draw the player,
see it moving and then go from there.
So let's do that.
So let's go to Main here.
I'm going to create a player.
I'm going to say players equal to player.
I need to pass an X,
Y and a width and height.
So I'm going to pass, let's say 100, 100
and let's make him 50 by 50.
And then what we can do now
is pass our player to the draw function.
We can then take player inside of here
and we can say, player don't draw
and we can pass the window.
Okay, so I will move the player in 1/2,
but for now, let's just
see if this is working,
if it's going to show up on the screen.
So let's run the code and notice
that now we have a red rectangle
in the top left hand corner.
Obviously nothing's happening right now.
We're not moving it around the screen.
We could see it showing.
So we have our player we're
drawing the player on the screen now.
We want to start
using some of these methods right, moving
left, moving right, etc..
So I want to separate my movement
into a function.
So I'm going to say define handle,
move like this.
And for this right
now, we'll just take in the player.
Now instead of handle move.
What we're going to do
is essentially check the keys
that are being pressed on the keyboard.
If you're pressing left
or you're pressing right,
then we'll move the character to the left
or to the right.
Eventually, we will check for collision
and we'll do all of that.
So I'm going to say
key is equal to pi game dark keys
actually
not key squeaks get underscore pressed.
This tells you all of the keys on the
keyboard that are currently being pressed.
And I'm going to say
if and actually this is going to be key
really we should call this keys, though,
because this makes a bit more sense.
We're going to say if keys and this is pi
game dot k underscore left.
This is the left arrow key
if you want it to use the a key
then you would use a like that.
Yeah,
actually I'll go with left arrow kicks.
That's what I usually do.
But you can use a
or swap it however you want.
And then I'm going to say
if this is the case, then player dots move
underscore left
and how much do I want to move
the player likes
we have to pass the velocity.
Well this is going to
be my player velocity. Right.
Okay.
Next I'm going to say if keys
and this is PI game.
Okay, underscore right.
Then I'm going to say player dots
move underscore right again same thing
I going to move this by my player
velocity.
Now it's important that before I do this,
I set my player velocity to be zero.
Now the reason this is the case is because
if I don't do this, what will happen
is as soon as I move left,
this is going to set my player velocity
right, which you can see here, my XFL,
it's going to set the X velocity.
Now, once
I set that, I'm going to continue moving
in that direction
until it gets set back to zero.
So if you wanted to make it
so, when you press a key,
you just continually move in that
direction until you press a different key.
Then you could omit this bonus case.
We only want to move
while you're holding down the key.
So I'm going to say player to Excel equals
zero.
There's a lot of other ways
to go about doing this,
but I just want to stay consistent
with our movement
because of
how we're going to do the gravity.
So for now, just bear with me.
We essentially set the velocity to zero
and then if we are moving left or right,
so for pressing these keys,
then we change the velocity to be,
you know, the negative player velocity
or the positive player velocity
based on the direction we're moving in.
Okay.
That's actually all we need
for handling the movement.
So let's put the handle movement function
where we're going to put this
we're going to put this before we drop.
So it's a handle move
when a passed my player.
All right now I need to make sure
before I do this that
I call my loop function okay
and I pass my ops.
And the reason I need to call loop
is because loop
is what actually moves my player, right?
If you look at loop, it's
moving my player in the x velocity
and y velocity direction.
Every single frame.
So if I set the x velocity,
well then I continue moving again.
If I said the y velocity,
I move in that direction.
But that only works if we're continually
calling this loop function.
Okay, good.
So we've made great progress so far.
Let's see if we can move our player
where if I've made a mistakes,
which are very likely.
So let's run the code and let's see.
Okay, so I'm going to hit my right key.
You can see I can move to the right
and I can move to the left.
Obviously, if I wanted to go up and down,
I could implement that.
But we want to have a jumping,
which I will show you in a second.
But we kind of need collision
before we can do jumping.
Very good. All is looking great so far.
Now let's implement gravity
so we kind of fall down.
Then we can do kind of the sprite sheets,
then we can do the collision
because the collision makes more sense.
I guess once we have the
the sprite sheets done.
So let's implement gravity.
Now gravity is a little bit complicated
because we want to have
like kind of a realistic gravity, right,
that actually implement
some basic physics.
What I mean by that is, rather than just
having a constant velocity,
we want to actually have an acceleration
for our gravity.
So as many of you know,
if you're in physics gravity,
the acceleration is -9.8
meters per second squared.
I believe that's what the acceleration is.
Anyway, in our game
we want to emulate something similar
to that where it feels like the longer
you're falling, the faster you fall.
You're not falling at a constant speed
that makes the game
just feel like really, really unrealistic.
So the first thing we need to do is pick
some value that we want our gravity to be.
And this is the acceleration of gravity.
So keep that in mind.
So for this, I'm going to make a variable
in my player class because it's
the only place we need it right now,
I'm going to say is equal to one.
So gravity is equal to one.
If you want gravity to be faster,
obviously you increment this value, right?
Make it large.
Okay, now inside of loop, this is where
we need to handle our gravity.
So every single frame in our loop,
we're going to increase the Y velocity
by our gravity.
However, how
we know how much to increase the velocity
by varies
on how long we've been falling for.
Yeah, I know this seems really weird,
but we essentially need to keep track
of how long we've been falling
so that we know how quickly we should be
increasing our velocity or how quick
we should be accelerating downwards.
So that means that I need to create
a variable here called self-taught count
and given we should really call a song
better, I'll call it fall count.
And this will essentially tell us, okay,
how long have we been in the air for?
How long have we been falling?
And we'll use this value to determine
how much we increment our velocity by.
So I'm now I'm going to say myself
the y underscore velocity and I'm
going to add to this the minimum of one
or and I'm going to take myself not count.
And this is my fall count
divided by the frames per second,
multiplied by the self-taught gravity.
Now, this isn't truly
what the acceleration would be, but
this will give us a kind of somewhat
realistic looking gravity in the game.
So just bear with me.
So what we're doing, we're taking our full
count, we're dividing it by FBC.
The point of this is that
if I want this value to be in seconds,
then I need to take whatever
my count is, which I'm going to increment
every single loop.
In fact, we'll do this right now,
plus equals
one and I divide it by EPS with my FBC 60.
As soon as this is 60
that I've been falling for 1/2,
I take that amount time,
I multiply it by my gravity
and then that tells me how much I'm
going to increment my y velocity by.
However, this is going to start out
being really, really small, just like
fractional decimal decimal amounts.
So just to make this a bit easier for us
when we do our collision,
I'm going to increment this
by the minimum of one or this value.
So every frame we're moving at least one
pixel down and it doesn't take us
like a full second before we really start
feeling any effect of gravity.
Hopefully that makes a bit of sense.
You guys are understanding me here,
but just bear with me.
I've experimented with these numbers
quite a bit,
so I think this should be fun.
Okay, so now that we have this,
what should happen when I just
click Run here is I should just start
falling immediately on the screen.
And obviously
until we have some platforms, a collision,
we can't really stop falling
if we have gravity.
But let's have a look
and let's see how it works right now.
Okay.
So you can see that I fall and notice
I'll do this again,
that I start falling slowly
and then it picks up the pace.
Right?
So this is somewhat realistic
to how gravity would actually work.
And that's what I was trying to implement
when I did this.
Now that we have done
that, it's time to move on
and have some kind of sprites or images.
I was going to do this later,
but I realized that we can't really do
the collision, which is going to be pixel
perfect collision
until we have some kind of images.
That's that's really
all we need. We need our sprites.
So what we need to do here first
is examine what our sprites look like
for our characters.
Now, remember all these characters
pretty much the exact same.
They just look different.
But in terms of their movements,
their animations, the number of images,
they're identical.
So whatever I show you for one of
these is the same for all of them.
Hence
why we can just kind of swap them out.
So when I go to Mask dude
here, let's zoom in.
You can see that
we have, for example, double jump.
I just picked a random sprite.
She now this sheet has six different
animations or six different frames
which represent what this guy
is going to look like while he's
kind of jumping
or double jumping in the air.
So what we need to do
is we need to split this one image
into the six individual images
and then loop through those images
at some frequency or some time
so that we can show them on the screen
and show an animation. Right.
We need to kind of manually do this.
Now, some of these are single frames
like falling is a single frame
that's easy hit.
Okay?
This is like,
you know, the guy disappears for a second,
kind of expands, goes back.
You get the point.
We want to loop through these
animations, idle single frame.
Actually,
no, idle. It's not a single frame.
It's a bunch of frames.
This guys arms
it kind of wagging up and down.
We have jump a single frame,
run a bunch of frames and then watch them.
Now notice here with these images
that they're in different directions
or let's say
they're all kind of facing, right?
So another thing we're going to have to do
is rotate
this image to face left
when our character is facing left.
So that's another thing
we have to handle that not only do
we just have to split these images up,
we also have to get a rotated version
of them so we can show
you moving in a different direction.
Same with jumping and with being idle.
Like whatever direction you're going.
We need to show
the image flipped in that direction,
so don't rotate or flip.
That's what we're going to do.
Okay, so let's do this
first thing I will do
actually, is I'll write the function
that will flip our image.
So I'm going to say flip sprites.
This is going to take in a list of sprites
and I'm going to return
pie game, dot transform,
dot flip and this is going to be sprites
true false notice as it says here,
this is indicating what directions
you want to flip in when I past.
True, this means flip in the extraction
when I pass false.
This means don't flip in the y direction.
If you want to flip both, you'd past
true twice, but we don't want to do that.
So I have pie
game to transform the flip sprite
and then this is going to be for sprite
in sprites
really I could call this image
but you get the point because we have flip
now we're going to write a
function which is load sprite
sheets
and should we call it sheet or sheets?
I think sheets is fine
and what this is going to do is load
all of the different sprite sheets
for our characters.
So it's going to give us a spreadsheet
for double jumping,
for hitting, for falling.
And then within our character we can pick
what sheet we want to be using,
what animations we want to loop through.
So I'm going to take in directory
one, in directory two.
And the reason I'm doing
this is so that I can load other images
that aren't just my characters
and this will be very dynamic.
I also want to take in the desired width
and height of my image
and if we need to load multiple directions
so I'm going to say direction equals
false is the default parameters
so that we only load like the left
and the right side
images like we flip the images
if you passed this equal to true.
Okay, now the first thing we need to do
is determine the path to the images
we're going to be loading.
So I'm going to say join assets
dir one, dir two.
Notice I can use join
because I imported this from oh stop path.
Okay, now I'm going to get
all of the images in this directory.
Now the way I do
that, as often as the images is equal to
and this is going to be f for F in list
directory again notice I can use that.
So import here.
We're going to list all of the things
that are inside of this path directory
and then we're going to say if
is file and then this is going to be join
path and F
so what this for loop is going to do here
this I forget what you actually call
this when you write a for loop in a list
anyways but this line is going to do
here is load every single file only file
that is inside of this directory.
So again,
we're just going to get every single
one of these file names
and then once we have this file names,
we can load that image
and we can then split that image up
into the individual images
that we want to get.
So we have images now I'm going to say
all sprites is equal to a dictionary.
And what I'm going to do with this
dictionary is have key value pairs
where the key is the,
let's say, animation style
and the value is all of the images
in that animation.
Okay.
So all sprites
now I'm going to say for image in images
and I'm going to say that my sprite sheet,
so the individual sprite sheet
I want to load here is going to be equal
to pie game dot image default load
and then this is going to be join
path and image and then dot convert alpha,
which is essentially going to allow me
to load a transparent background image.
Okay.
So we are loading the image
which is just one of the files
that we found right from this path.
And we just need
to append the path to it, right?
So whatever the path to the directory is,
plus the image name.
Okay, we're going to load that in.
We're going
to get the transparent background.
Now that we have this, we need to get
all of the sprites in this image.
So going to say sprites is equal to
and now it's going to be a list okay.
So again, the processes load
all of the different files.
Okay, we have all the files,
these are sprite sheets.
Now we need to get all the individual
images from the spreadsheet
and load those, get some going,
say for I in range
and then this is going to be sprite sheet
get underscore width
integer divided by the width of the image
that we're loading now.
Width is going to be the width
of an individual image
inside of our animation
or inside of our spreadsheet.
So if I know this is say 32 pixels,
I pass 32
and then it gives me a bunch of images
that are 32 pixels white.
That's how I'm doing the loading.
So that's why it took width
and height here. Okay.
Now that we have that,
we're going to say surface is equal to
game dot surface
and then this is going to be width
height.
We're going to pass py game dot s
c which allows us to load again
transparent images.
And then I'm going to pass 32 here,
which is the depth.
Don't worry about that.
But this just
what we need to load these images
and now we need to create a rectangle
which is going to tell us where
in this image, an image
being the sprite sheet that we want
to take, an individual image
from and bullet it onto the surface.
I know this seems really weird,
but what we're doing
is we're going to create a surface
that's the size of our desired individual
animation frame.
We're then going to grab that animation
frame from our main, main image.
We're going to draw it onto the surface
and then we're going to kind of export
that surface.
That's the way that we have to do this.
So I'm going to say
rectangle is equal to PI game
dot rect.
And for the rect this is the location
on our original image
that we want to grab this new frame from.
So I'm going to say this is
I multiplied by my width and then zero
and then the width
and the height of my image.
Okay, now that I have that, I'm
going to say surface dot bullet.
Bullet really means draw
and I'm going to draw my sprite sheet,
but I'm going to draw this at zero zero
and I'm only going
to draw the portion of it
which is my rectangle.
So notice this is my source,
this is the destination,
and this is the area of my source
that I'm drawing.
So in position zero zero,
which is the top left hand
corner of my new surface,
I'm drawing my sprite sheet,
but I'm only drawing the frame
from my sprite sheet that I want.
Okay, then I'm going to say Sprite,
start, append,
and I'm going to append my surface,
but I'm going to make my surface
two times larger
because that's what I want to do.
I want this to be bigger
than the default size.
So I'm going to say pie game dots
transform dot scale to x
and then I'm going to scale to X
my surface.
Okay.
Again,
I know this seems a bit complicated, but
now we have essentially stripped out
all of the individual frames.
We've just scaled them up
to be double their size.
So if they're 32 by 32,
we've made them 64 by 64.
That's what scale to X does.
And now we need to handle the directions.
Okay, so now we need to say
if direction,
then all underscore sprites
and this is going to be image
dot replace, it's going to be dot PG,
it's going to be an empty string
plus underscore, right
is equal to our sprites.
Now we're going to copy the same thing,
copy this and put it here
and now this is going to be underscore
left is equal to
and this is going to be flip
sprites.
So what we're saying here is
if you want a multidirectional animation,
then we need to add two keys
to our dictionary here
for every single one of, our animations.
So for falling, for hit, for idle,
we need a left and a right side.
So the right side
is the one that we already have.
So we're going to say,
okay, all sprites at and then we're just
going to strip off the dot page
from whatever the name of our base image
was that's going to give us run, jump,
idle, hit whatever the name of our files
and then we're going to spend
on her school right or underscore left
now for underscore right, that's
our basic sprites for underscore left.
We need to flip all of those sprites
and we already wrote the function that did
now otherwise
then what we'll do is say all
underscore sprites at image dot replace
dot pinky with an empty string.
This just removes that up pinky and
then it's going to be equal to sprites.
Okay then we can return
all of our sprites.
All right.
Probably one of the most complicated
aspects of the code that we need to write.
So don't worry, we are done now
with loading images at least.
Well, we'll have to load our block,
but that's going to be a lot easier
than loading our sprite sheets.
So this now will load
a spreadsheet for us.
Now that we've load our sprite sheet,
we actually want to start using this.
So inside of player
we are going to grab our images.
So I'm going to say my sprites is equal to
and it's going to be load
spreadsheets and now I need to pass
what I want to load.
So now I need to pass the main character
directory.
And actually this is main characters.
Okay, so have a look here.
So inside of assets, right?
Yes. So we're joining assets with Dir
one in dirt two.
So the first directory I pass
is main characters
and then I pass the second directory,
which is the name of the character
I want to load.
So mask dude,
ninja frog Pinkman or Virtual Guy,
you can pick whatever one you want.
I'm going to go with mask dude for now.
Now for width and height.
Be within the height of this,
going to be 32.
So make sure you do this 30 to 32 and
then you pass through because we want a
sprite.
So both the left and right side
animations, that's what we want.
Okay.
Now that we have that,
we are going to change our draw here
so that we're drawing our Sprite
now for for now, we're just going to draw
like one simple sprite
to see how it looks on the screen.
Then I'll go through animating the Sprite
and showing you how that works.
Okay.
So rather than pong
game, do draw out rect.
I'm going to say self
that sprite is equal to
and then this is going to be self-taught
sprites at idle.
Now Idle is one of the name
for our animations, right?
So if we go here
you can see we have idle jump etc.
So I'm accessing the key
from my dictionary
and then I'm going to access
the first frame of this key, which is zero
because every single key
is a whole sprite, right?
So now that I have my Sprite, I'm
going to say window applet
and then this is going to be self
doubt sprite and I'm going to bullet
this at self-taught rect on x
and self doubt rec dot
y, which is the position on the screen.
And then if we want, we can just
turn off the gravity for right now so
we can kind of see it on the screen
and it doesn't just disappear.
Okay, let's try this out.
Let's just
make sure it actually loaded correctly.
So let me run this and we are there.
Okay,
so let me see what error we got here.
Run this again.
It said key key error idle.
Okay.
So the issue here is that since we load
a directional sprite,
we need to reference either
idle right or idle left.
So we can actually do this
by saying idle underscore plus self
direction.
And then so long as we set the direction
which we did here to left,
this should work.
So now it'll change
based on if we're going left or right.
So actually you'll see that it should swap
as we change directions.
Okay, let's try this now.
All right,
so now we have this guy facing left.
If I go right,
he turns right, left, right.
Perfect.
Now we want to see him animated.
So as I was saying,
let's get into the animation.
Now, this actually can be pretty easy
because we've already loaded
in all of the frames that we need.
So I know that
we don't have a ton to show right now,
but a lot of the hard stuff
is done for this video,
so just make you aware
that all this time has not gone to waste.
What we need to do is we need to come up
with something that has a way
to kind of update our Sprite or update
what we're showing on the screen.
So I'm going to write a function here
called Update Sprite,
and I'm going to take itself
and I'm going to say Sprite sheet
is equal to idle.
Now, this is the default spreadsheet.
If we're not moving, if we're not jumping,
if we're not falling,
if not being attacked, we use idle.
However, if we are running
or we're doing something else,
then we use the other sprite.
So now I'm going to say if my self-taught
x velocity does not equal zero,
then my sprite sheet
is going to be equal to run.
So if I have some velocity in the x
direction, then I'm running, right?
So then I want to change this
to the run spreadsheet.
So I'm going to say my sprite sheet
name is equal to and this is going to be
my sprite sheet plus and then underscore
and then plus the self support direction.
Perfect.
So now we just change the main sprite
sheet name so it'll run, jump, whatever,
we add the direction to it.
And this tells us,
you know what exact sprite sheet we want.
Okay, now that we have that,
what we're going to do is say the sprite
that we could be using for this
animation is equal to self dot sprites
and this is in all capitals
at the sprite sheet name.
All right.
Now that we've done that,
we need to essentially iterate
through these sprites
and every few seconds change
the sprite that we're showing
so that it looks like we're animating.
So we need to add a variable here
that is going to account
for the amount of delay
between changing sprites.
So I'm going to call this the animation
delay and make this equal to five.
Okay.
Now I'm going to come here
and I'm going to say that my Sprite index,
which essentially is Sprite
that I want to be using here,
is equal to my self dot animation count,
which we're going to increment
the second integer divided
by my self-taught animation
delay modulus by the length of the sprites
that I'm using.
Now, let's just put some parentheses
here for order of operations
and let me explain what we're doing.
So we have an animation delay
that's every five frames.
So every five frames
we want to show a different sprite
in whatever animation we're using.
So if we're running left, if we're idle,
whatever, it doesn't matter.
We want to show a different one.
So we take the animation count,
we divide it by five,
and then we mod
whatever the line of our sprites is.
So if we have five sprites,
then when we're on, say, animation,
count ten,
we're showing the second sprite right?
You get the idea.
So this is dynamic.
This will not work for any single sprite.
So hopefully you guys understand how
this animation count is kind of working.
But we're trying to pick a new index
every animation frames
from our sprites,
but we want this to be dynamic.
So we're using the length of the sprites.
And again, it's just it's dynamic work
for any single sprite sheet we have now.
We need to select our sprites.
We say self-doubt
Sprite is equal to the Sprite,
so we have access to at the Sprite index.
Then we update our animation count by one.
Now what we can do
is remove this here from draw
and we just need to now call the self dot
update sprite from our loop.
Okay.
So now that we've done that,
we'll call this, we'll update our Sprite
every single frame and then we'll draw
that updated sprite on the screen.
Okay, let's run
it and let's see what we get.
Notice, we have idle notice.
I can run to the right
and I can run to the left.
Now, if you think this is too slow
and some of you may argue that it is,
then you just make this number smaller.
So make this three.
Okay.
And now it looks like
we're running a little bit faster.
So it's completely up to you
how you want to animate this.
I'll do two for now
and let's see if this looks better.
So actually,
I think three was a pretty kind of happy
medium here since go back to three again,
you guys can change this. It's up to you
how you want it to look.
Okay, now that we have that, we're
almost ready to start doing collision.
However, we need to introduce
something known as a mask.
So I'm going to make another method
here and say, define update.
Now what we need to do here
is essentially update the rectangle
that bounds our character
based on the sprite that we're showing.
So it's different
like kind of sizes to the sprites, right?
Some are a little bit taller,
some are little push
the left or pushed to the right.
And the rectangle that we have,
we want to be essentially the same
as the sprite that we have.
Again, I know this seems a bit weird,
but we're going to do this
are going to say self
direct is equal to self dot
and then it's going to be sprite
get underscore rect.
And we're going to say
that the top left of this rectangle
is equal to the self direct dot x
and these self-correct dot y.
Now pretty much what's going to happen
here is depending on what Sprite we have,
if it's slightly smaller, slightly bigger,
whatever,
we're going to constantly
adjust the rectangle
specifically we're going to adjust
the width and the height of it,
but we're going to use the same
x and Y position that we've had
for this rectangle.
If you don't understand that, it's fine.
It's not a massive deal.
This line is not crazy important,
but it's just trying to make sure
that the rectangle we're using
to kind of bound our character is
constantly adjusted
based on the sprite that we're using.
Now, what's more important
is this line, which is updating the mask.
We're going to say self,
that mask is equal do pi game dot mask
dot from the surface
and it's going to be self-taught sprite.
Now let me quickly explain this.
A mask is essentially a mapping of all
of the pixels that exist in the Sprite.
So whenever we draw
something on the screen,
we're really drawing a rectangle, right?
But the rectangle may not have
nontransparent pixels, right?
So only part of the rectangle
is actually filled in.
Hence why we get kind of a circular image,
a dynamic image, whatever.
So what this mask tells us
is where there's actually images
or where is not
where there's actually pixels. Sorry.
And this mask allows us to perform
pixel perfect collision
because we can overlap it with another
mask and make sure that we only say two
objects collide if pixels are colliding,
not if the rectangular box is colliding.
If we did rectangular collision,
then it constantly looks like
we're hitting something
even when we're not.
Because the rectangle for
our character is larger than where
all of the pixels for our character are.
You've probably seen this
in a lot of games before,
but what the mask does is solve
that problem for us
and allow us to do this
kind of pixel perfect collision.
It's very important,
though, that you call this mask.
If you don't do that, this
collision is not going to work properly.
It needs to be mask because the sprite
that we inherited from here
uses this rectangle and uses this
mask property when it does the collision.
All right.
So now that we've done this,
I just need to call this function.
So I'm going to go here
and say self-deport update
and now we're done
with most of what we need
for the player.
So what we want to do now is
we want to start
adding blocks onto the screen
and then letting a player fall, collide
with those blocks
and then be able to jump.
Because obviously we can't really jump
until we have something to jump off of.
Otherwise, jumping in thin air
doesn't make a ton of sense.
All right.
So let's create another class here.
And this class I'm going to call object.
And this will be a base class that we use
for essentially all of our objects,
just so that the collision will be uniform
across all of them.
So again, we're going to inherit
from the Sprite class from PY game
and we're going to define
our initialization.
So define a net.
We're taking self x, y, width
and height and name
which for now is going to be equal to none
but could be equal to something.
Or they're going to say
super dot underscore underscore init
which will
initialize the superclass,
which is this one right here.
Now the reminds me we need this as well
in our constructor for player.
So let's put that in player.
Okay, now we need to define a rectangle
and say self.
That rectangle is equal to py game
dots rect
and then this is going to be x, y,
width and height.
We're going to say
self-taught image is equal
to py game
dot surface
and then this is going to be width height
and then we're going to say py game
dot source
alpha like that
if we spell py game correctly.
Again, this just supports transport
transparent images for us.
My apologies.
And then we're going to say
self-taught width equals width.
Self-taught height
is equal to height and self-taught name
is equal to name.
Where I'm going to say define draw,
I'm going to say self and window like this
and then we're going to say win doublets.
And this is going to be self-taught image
and then we're going to split this
at the self dot rect
dot x and he's self-correct
dot y okay I know I went fast.
Essentially, this is just a base class.
We're not actually going
to instantiate this, but this just defines
all of the properties
that we need for a valid sprite.
So we have a rectangle, we have our image,
we are drawing the image
and then in a class.
So we're about to use,
we're going to inherit from this
and it will just save us from rewriting
a bunch of functionality
that we don't need.
So the idea here
is that all we do is modify this image.
When we change the image now,
the draw function will automatically draw
it accurately on the screen for us.
And all these other properties
we're just saving
in case we need them from our child class.
So I'm going to make a class now
called BLOCK.
This is going to inherit from object.
Now we're going to say define init
around second self, x, y
and the size of our block.
Now since the block is a square,
we just need one dimension not too right.
We're going to say super
dot underscore underscore init.
We're going to pass X-Y
size size.
So notice
this constructor requires four arguments.
We have to pass four here.
We just duplicate size because
it's the same for the width and height.
Then we're going to say
block is equal to load block,
which is going be a function that we write
in a second that will take a size.
We're going to say self, image, doublet.
Imagine that this is going to give us
an image, okay, which it will in a second.
When we write it, we're going to hit
the block at position zero zero
and then we're going to say
the self dump mask is equal to py game
don't masked from surface
we're going to take our self that image
and there you go we have our mask
which we need for collision.
Okay, again,
I know this is a little confusing.
It'll make more sense in a second,
but we're using this object
which now has this draw function
built in for us.
It also defines
subtract, it defines the width and height
and all of that stuff.
Here, what we do
is we get the image that we need,
which we're going to write this in 1/2,
then we bullet this image to our image,
which is a pie game surface.
And then we say self-doubt mask
you you'll do piling up to mask
the from surface self-doubt image.
We also could just say self
that image is equal to the block,
but let's do it this way for now.
Okay,
so let's now write our get block function,
which I'm going to do beneath
our get sprite sheet or load spreadsheets.
I'm going to say get
and I'm going to take in a size.
Now what I need to do here
is essentially find the block that I want
in my train folder.
So I'm going to say path is equal to join
assets and
then this is going to be terrain like so.
And then we're going to use the terrain
dot PNG file.
So if I go here, you could see that
we have terrain, terrain
and then what
we want to do is load this block,
which I'll be showing you
how to load in 1/2.
Okay.
Now that we have done that, now
that we have our path, we're going to say
the image is equal to py game
dot image, dot load and we're going to say
path again to convert alpha
so that we get a transparent background.
We don't really need it for this one.
But just in case later we load string
does have transparency.
We will and we're going to say surface
is equal to pi game dot surface.
And for the surface we're in a past size
size which is the width
and the height of our surface and past
pi game dot source alpha with a
depth sorry of 32
we're going to say
rectangle is equal to pi game dot rect
and then this is going to be 96
zero size size.
Now let me slow down for 1/2.
If we go to terrain, we can see that
we want to load this guy right here.
Now, I've already done the math.
This image starts
96 pixels from the top of the screen.
So that's the reason I'm putting 96 there
because I want to start at 96.
So 96 zero is my position
and then I want to load the size of this,
which I think is going to be either 96
or 64 or something along those lines.
Anyways, if I wanted to load, say, this
train image, then I would still have 96.
But my y position would be different.
In fact, the Y position would probably be
a little bit less than 96.
It might be 80, it might be 85.
I'd have to experiment with it
to see exactly where this image starts.
But I just want you to understand that
what I'm passing here,
when I say something like 96 zero,
I'm passing the position
that I want to load the image
from from the image, right?
So I'm picking out a part of this image
and this is like 96 zero.
That's where I am picking it right here.
Hopefully you guys understand that.
But if you want to load
a different train image,
then you have to adjust these
to be the starting position, the top left
hand corner of whatever image it is
you want to load here.
And if yeah,
I was going to say
we can load different one,
but I don't want to waste time guessing
which one it is.
So you guys can mess with that
if you want.
But let's just load this top one,
which I already know works.
Okay,
now that we have that ran, it's a surface
dump blitz
and we're going to blitz the image
and again,
we're going to blitz it at zero zero,
but we're only
to hit the area of it
which is represented by the rectangle.
Then we are going to return high game dot
transform dot scale to x surface.
Okay, so we've passed what size
we want our block to be.
Then we create an image
that is of that size.
Okay.
We then say rectangle is equal to 96
zero size size.
Right?
And then we blitz
this image onto our surface,
which will be the image that we return.
And we return this scaled up by two times.
So it just doubles the size that we pass
here.
You don't have to scale it
if you don't want,
but I want it to be larger
so I am scaling.
Now I understand again, Spike,
if using this size is going to be
the dimension of this block,
so you want to pass
whatever the size from this sprite sheet
is that you want to get.
In our case, I think it's going to be 64
or something along those lines.
So that's what size will be.
You guys can mess around with this,
but really
what you're going to be changing
is these two values and the size.
That's what you're going to change
when you want to load a different image
for your block.
Okay, so now for block,
we have to block or load block.
I call it load block or get block.
I called it get block.
Okay,
so let's change this to be get block.
All right.
So now have a block.
Let's create a block.
Let's draw a block on the screen and let's
do some collision with our blocks.
Okay?
So let's go here to Main
and let's say blocks is equal to and let's
just start by creating a single block.
So for our block, let's
just put it kind of randomly
on the screen for now
where do I want to put this?
Let's go with something like
actually, I'm going to create
a variable first, say block size.
Let's put this at zero height
minus the block underscore size.
BLOCK size is going to be equal to 96.
Okay.
And then for the size we're going to pass,
block size.
Okay.
So the size of our block is actually 96.
I lied.
It is not 64. It's going to be 96.
So we're going to create a block
that's going to be positioned at zero
height, minus block size,
which is going to put it
at the bottom of the screen.
And then the size is this.
Now we need to draw blocks.
So I'm going to pass
blocks to my draw function.
Okay.
And I'm going to go here
and actually let's call this objects
and we're going to say form objects
or for objects in objects.
If we could type this correctly,
object dot draw.
I'm struggling here with the typing
and we will draw this on the window.
Okay, so we have our block now.
Let's quickly look at this again right.
We load her image.
Okay, we got a block,
we have her size now.
We create the block down here
and then we put it on the screen.
Let's run it and see if we get a block.
And of course, we got an error.
What's it say here?
I need to run this again.
I take zero positional arguments,
but one was given.
Okay, so let's go to our player class here
and we can see update.
I forgot to add the self parameter, so
let's add that in and that should fix it.
Okay.
So now you can see that we have a block.
So now what we can do is create a whole
floor of blocks if we want to do that
and then we'll implement gravity
and then collision with the blocks so that
you can see that you can land on the block
and we can jump off of the block.
All right, so let's make a whole floor.
So to make a floor,
we can do this instead.
Floor is equal to we're going to say.
BLOCK It's going to be high
times.
BLOCK Size.
It's going to be height,
minus block size, block size
for I in range.
And I'm going to say a negative width
with times two.
And we're going to divide this
by the block size
and by block size.
Then for my
blocks, let's actually just
replace this
and instead we'll just pass for
okay, what I've done here with this
for loop is I've said I want to
create blocks that go kind of to the left
and to the right of the screen.
So I don't want to just fill
the current screen
because we're going to have scrolling
background in the second,
which will implement in a minute.
Anyways, I want to have some kind of go
into the left and some going to the right.
So I'm taking my negative
with over the block size,
which is how many blocks
I want to the left side of the screen.
And then I'm taking my width times
two and I'm integer
dividing that by the block size again.
That's how many
I want to the right of the screen.
Then I'm taking I, I'm multiplying it
by my block size, which is telling me
the x coordinate position
that I want my block to be on.
And then
this is always going to be same because I
want it to be at the bottom of the screen
and then for my block size, well,
I want that to always be the same.
Okay.
So let's run this now and see what we get.
And now we get a bunch of blocks.
So now that we have these blocks, let's
make it so we can collide with the blocks.
And so we have gravity
and we actually fall onto those blocks.
So the collision all right.
Collision is a little complicated, but
let's write it and let's see how we can
how we can get it going here.
So inside of Handle Move is where
we're going to handle our collision,
which means
we need to have a list of objects
that we can potentially be colliding with.
Now, we are going to write a function here
called
Handle Vertical Collision
because we need to handle the vertical
and horizontal collision differently.
For now,
we'll just start with vertical orientation
player objects and the displacement
in why that we just moved
now we're going to have collided
underscore is equal to a list
I'm going to say for object in objects.
These are all the objects
we could be colliding with.
I'm going to say if my game
dot sprites, dot collide mask
and then we're going to pass our player
and our object.
Now, remember, I told you
Collision was going to be simple.
Well, there you go.
This is all you need to do to determine
if two objects are colliding.
The reason we can do this
is because our objects we've inherited
from the Sprite class and on them
we have a mask.
So we're going to use this mask property
as well as the rectangle property.
When we collide with the mask.
So I passed my player,
I passed my object and this will tell me
if I am colliding with my object.
Perfect.
Now if I am, I'm going to do some stuff
differently
depending on what direction
I'm colliding in.
So if I'm hitting the top of the object,
it's going to be different
than if I'm hitting the bottom.
So we need to handle that here.
So I'm going to say if my displacement
Y is greater
than zero, really,
this should be velocity.
But this fine, then
what I'm going to do is place my character
on top of the object it collided with,
so I'm no longer colliding with it.
Now, what this is saying
is if I'm moving down on the screen,
so if I'm moving down,
then that would mean I was colliding
with the top of this object.
So if I am, I'm going to take the bottom
of my player
rectangle, which is my bottom,
my players feet essentially.
And I'm going to make it equal
the top of the object.
I'm colliding with this.
Another advantage of using rectangles.
You can use this kind of bottom
and top property and avoid having to do,
you know, add the height
and that kind of stuff.
So that's what I'm going to do now.
Otherwise I'm going to say
if my display so y is less than zero
and I suppose this can be an elf,
then what I will do
is say my player direct top
is equal to the object rect bottom
because if I'm moving up,
which means I have a negative velocity,
then I am hitting the bottom of an object.
So I need to make my top
be equal to the bottom.
Okay.
This just makes it so you don't like, say,
stay inside of the object.
Excuse me?
You go outside of it
and it looks like you collided,
but you didn't go through the object.
Now, one thing we also need to do here
is need to call the method player
down landed and player dot hit head,
which I've not yet created.
And we're going to write these to handle
what happens when we land on a block
and when we hit our head on a block.
Okay, then we're going to say collided
objects, dot append
and we're going to append our object and
we're going to return our collided objects
just so that we know what objects
we collide with so that we can check
if we collided with like fire or a certain
special object or something like that.
Okay, so let's handle vertical collision.
Now we need to write the landed
and hit head method.
So let's go to player and let's do this.
So I'm going to say let's do it here.
Landed
Self.
Now what do we do if we landed?
Well, if we just landed, then we need to
reset our gravity, our fall counter.
So we're going to say self
dot fall count is equal to zero.
So that way we stop like adding
gravity, right?
Okay.
What else do we need to do if we land?
We need to say that our y velocity
is equal to zero.
If we let it on a block, stop
moving us down and I'll add this in.
Now we're going to say our self,
that jump count is equal to zero.
We're going to do something
with jumping that involves double jumping.
So we'll have a jump counter.
I'll just put this here now
and then we'll use it later.
Okay, so that's if we landed.
Otherwise I'm going to say
define hit head for self.
I'm going to say self doubt count equals.
If we hit our head,
I want to reverse our velocity
so that now we move down
because we're moving up, right?
So I'm going to multiply my velocity
by negative ones that when I hit my head,
I kind of bounce off the block
and go downwards.
That's what's going to look most natural.
Okay, so that's all we need for right now,
for hitting the head.
Now we can add our gravity back
and when we add our gravity back,
what's going to happen is will fall.
We'll hit the block,
we'll move us to the top of the block,
and then we should just build a move
on top of the block.
Let's see if that's going to work, though.
Although it's not going to work
if we don't add the function call.
So let's add
the function call here in handle move.
We're going to say
handle vertical.
We'll pass the player,
the objects and the player y velocity.
And the y velocity is essentially
how much we just moved right.
Okay, very good.
Now let's make your handle move.
We need to pass our floor,
so let's do that.
All right, let's run the code.
Let's see what we get.
And boom, look, we land on a block
and we can now run on top of the block
and everything is looking very good to me.
Okay, so that's pretty good.
Now that we're on top of a block,
we can jump
and then we can deal with hitting blocks.
What do you call this?
Horizontally, right?
So that we can't, like, run into a block
and we'll also make the background scroll
and then we'll be pretty good.
We'll have a lot of this tutorial
finished.
I want it to make us jump. Yes,
let's make a jump.
Okay.
So let's go to our player
and let's create a variable here.
Self-taught jump
underscore is equal to zero.
Now, based on the way of coded,
this jumping is actually quite easy.
I can say define jump self
and when we jump all we're going to
do is say self doubt
y underscore velocity is equal
to the negative of self dog
gravity multiplied
by whatever factor you want in
terms of the speed of your jump.
So I'm going to multiply gravity by eight.
The reason I'm doing this negative
is that I jump up in the air, right?
So now that I've done this will happen
is as soon as I hit the jump key,
I'll jump up into the air.
It's pretty straightforward.
And the reason that's going to happen
is because my y velocity will change
and what will bring me down
is the fact that inside of my loop,
if I go to where loop is, I'm constantly
applying downward gravity.
So what I'm doing is changing
my velocity to go upwards
and then I'm letting gravity take me down.
So that's kind of the benefit
of how we've quoted this.
Jumping is very easy.
Now I'm also going to reset my animation
count to zero.
I'm going to say my jump count
plus equals one.
I'm going to say
if the self-taught jump underscore count
is equal to
one, this means that I'm double jumping.
So if the jump counts equal to one
when I hit jump, that means it's
just going to be equal to two.
Now, let me take this.
Sorry and put this down here.
Then I will say self
account is equal to zero.
Yeah, I think so.
That makes sense.
No, I want to do it this way, sir.
Okay, so what I'm trying to do here
is make it so that as soon as I jump,
I essentially get rid of any gravity
I've already obtained.
So let's say I was, like, falling.
And then I landed and then I jumped.
There would be some gravity on me
keeping me on the ground.
So I want to remove that gravity
so that when I jump up,
it's in the factor,
like it's not taking into account
and then I'll start applying the gravity
after I jump.
Hopefully that makes a bit
of sense, but this should say
fall count.
So as soon as I jump, I'm resetting
the fall count to be equal to zero
so that any gravity
I've accumulated I'm removing.
But I'm only doing that
if this is the first jump I'm making.
Because for the second jump
I want you to have to time it based on
like when you're jumping, right?
So if you jump a second time close
to when you jump the first time,
you will jump higher than if you jumped at
like the peak of your jump
when you're gravity would be the highest.
Okay. I don't know if that makes sense,
but just just fall along here.
This I mess with this before this works,
trust me.
All right.
So we have jumping now.
I think that's all we really need.
Jumping? Yeah, that seems good to me.
So now if we want to jump, let's make it.
So when we hit space, we jump
so we can do that inside of handle move.
Actually, I'm not going to do it.
Handle, move.
I'm going to do it here in the event loop.
And the reason for this
is that if I do it in handle move,
what's going to happen
is if I press the jump key
and I hold the jump key down, I'm
going to keep jumping a bunch of times.
I don't want to do that.
I just want to jump
once when I hit the key
and then I have to release the key
and press it again to jump.
This tells me if I'm holding down the key,
what I'm going to do in here
tells me if I released the key.
Yeah, you'll see.
Yeah, this is the dude.
So I'm going to say if event type is equal
to PI game dot key down,
then we say
if events dorky is equal to pi game.
Okay, underscore space and
my player dot jump count is less than two.
So I'm going to allow
double jumping. Right.
So I'll have two jumps
then I'm going to say player dot jump.
Okay,
that should be all we need for jumping.
So let's try it out
and let's see if this works
and I can jump
and notice I can kind of run and jump
at the same time.
Now what I'll do now is add
like falling and jumping animations
because obviously it looks kind of weird
right now when I'm jumping,
but there you go. We can jump. Nice.
Okay, so let's add the the animations now.
So if we go to update Sprite,
all we need to do here is we'll say if
self dot and actually
I need to refer to my cheat sheet here
because this is a bit more complicated.
I thought, I mean to say if not self if
self doubt y underscore velocity does not
equal zero, then what I will do is say if
self-taught jump count equals equals one,
then I'm going to say
my sprite sheet is equal to jump.
I'm going to say self, self
don't jump count equals equals to.
Then my spreadsheet is equal to double.
Now this is actually going to be
if my velocity is less than zero,
which means I'm moving up.
Now, the next one that I want to add
is I want to say if
and actually these are all going to be LFS
Well not that one,
but this one I'm going to say f myself.
The y underscore
vowel is greater than zero this means.
I'm moving down, then my spreadsheet
should be equal to fall.
Okay,
so this
is handling regular jump and double jump
and this is telling me
if I'm falling, let's try it now
and let's see what happens when I jump.
Okay,
so it's kind of glitching a little bit.
The reason this is happening,
I believe, is
because we are applying gravity
even while we're on the ground.
So my y velocity
is always greater than zero
and something greater than zero
that's greater than zero again.
So I will show you how to fix this.
All right.
So actually, the way that I'm going to fix
this is a bit of a hack,
but it's it's going to be good.
No work here.
So I'm actually going to say if my self
the Y velocity is greater than self,
dot's gravity times two.
Now the reason I'm going to do this for
fall is so that I don't immediately
start glitching into this false state
when I have a really low amount of gravity
being applied to me
when I've gone off the block
and then I've fallen down to the block.
So let me show you what I mean by
just kind of running the code here.
So You can see that
what happens is when I hit the block,
when I collide with it, it's
going to reset my gravity count
and then I'm going to kind of spawn
to the top of the block.
So when I'm on the top of the block, going
to be slowly falling down to the block.
Then I'm going to hit the block.
When I hit the block, it's going
do the same thing.
It's going to bring me to the top, reset
my gravity count.
So what was happening before is that
we would go to the top of the block
and then our gravity would increase
a tiny bit, right, to increase
to be one pixel
per second or something along those lines,
which would mean we were falling.
So then we were falling.
We hit the block and then it reset it so
it kept glitching between the two states.
So what I've done is just made it.
So we have to have a significant amount
of gravity
before it starts showing that false state.
So now it doesn't look glitchy on the
screen as I'm jumping around.
And you
can see that what actually happened is
when I jump
and I get to the peak of my jump,
you can see that
it starts the falling state
because right now
my velocity is change directions.
Right now I'm going down.
Okay, so now we have jumping,
now we have running around
and colliding with blocks
then quite a bit actually.
The next thing I want to do is make it
so that objects move on the screen.
Then we will do our horizontal collision
and then we will pretty much be done
after I add kind of that
like fire state, right?
Or that let's call it a trap,
something like that.
Okay.
So we want to do scrolling background.
Scrolling
background is actually fairly easy.
The way that we do a scrolling background
is we simply offset
every single thing that we're drawing
on the screen by a certain amount.
So any object that we have,
we don't change its position at all.
We just change
how we're drawing it on the screen
so it doesn't affect any of our collision.
All it affects is what's seen, right?
So what's happening in
the background is we may be colliding
at a really far position to the right.
We're showing the position
currently on the screen.
You see what I mean?
But what this involves
is having some offset
X, which I'm going to say is equal to zero
now the way that I want to have it
and I'll just illustrate here,
is that when I'm on the screen,
I only start scrolling the background
when I get close to the edge.
So like here, right?
It would start scrolling.
Whereas if I'm in the middle
and I'm kind of moving like this,
don't want it to scroll the background
until I get to the edge.
Oh, also notice you can double jump here.
I kind of forgot to mention that part,
so I'm going to implement that where
essentially once
we reach a certain boundary,
then the screen will start scrolling.
All right, so how do we do this?
Well, we can do it
just directly inside of our loop here.
We're going to do it here.
We're going to say if B player dot rect
dot x minus the offset x
plus the player direct dealt with.
And actually,
now that I think of this, we're
just going to do this, we're going to say
if the player dot rect dot right
which will account for the width minus
the offset x is greater than or equal to
the width
minus a variable
that I'm going to write in a second,
which is scroll area
width and any Blair dot
x underscore
velocity is greater than zero.
Then we
are going to say offset underscore x
and this is going to be plus
B player x velocity.
All right, let me just write this variable
then I'll explain how this works,
because we also have to do the other side.
So as I scroll area with is equal to 200.
What that means is that
when I get to 200 pixels on the left
or 200 pixels on the right of the screen,
I start scrolling,
okay, so here what I'm doing is
I'm checking if I am moving to the right.
That's what this checks.
If my x velocity is greater than zero,
that means I'm moving to the right
and this is checking
if my character is right on the screen,
like if it's crossed a specific boundary.
So I take whatever
the right position of my player is,
which could be very far off the screen.
I subtract
whatever offset we currently have.
So if we're offsetting everything
by 100 pixels, for example,
I subtract that so I know where
I'm actually
showing the character on the screen
and I say if that's greater than the width
minus the scroll area width,
which means I'm at say 700 pixels,
something like that on the right side
of the screen, then I'm going to offset
the screen by whatever the velocity was
that my player just moved to.
Right?
So that will make it look like I'm
scrolling.
Now we can say or and do
the exact same thing for the left side.
So I'm going to say if player dot rect
dot left
and this is actually going to be
is going to be plus the offset.
I'm going to check
if it's plus or if it's minus.
No, it's going to be minus again. Minus.
The offset x is less than or equal
to the scroll area width
and my player dot
x underscore value is less than zero.
Then I want to do this now.
Let's move this down on the screen a bit.
I'm just going to add some parentheses
that my condition is
correct.
Okay. So I think that should be good.
Again, I'm checking to the left
and to the right side.
If I'm moving to the left,
I want to check if I'm at that boundary,
if I'm checking to the right,
or if I'm moving to the right.
So I want to check if I'm at that boundary
and then I increment my offset X.
Now, all I have to do to account for
this is add an offset X
to my draw function and draw
every single object offset by this x.
So I'm going to go
here, let's say offset, underscore x.
And now just to all of my draw
functions, I'm going to pass
offset x,
offset underscore x,
I'm going to go to all my draw functions
and I'm going to add this
offset X
and what I'm going to do is just subtract
the offset X from the exposition.
I'm drawing everything out
since it minus offset x
and we'll take in the offset underscore x.
Okay.
Now the reason this works,
if I move to the left,
my offset x is going to be negative,
which means everything
is going to push to the right side
because we're adding to the position
for it.
If I move to the left side or sorry
if I move to the right side,
the offset X is going to be positive,
which means everything
going to move to the left.
So it has a scrolling background effect.
Let's just run it though
and see if it works.
Then I can fix it if it doesn't.
Okay, so I start running here.
You can see that now
the floor is going to start going with me
once I reach this boundary.
However, on this side, right, like what
I'm in the middle is not doing anything.
I have to get to a certain boundary
which is kind of invisible on the screen,
and then it starts scrolling with me,
which is what I wanted to do.
And then notice if I jump here, boom,
I fall off the platform.
Let's do collision with blocks
in the horizontal direction.
So to do that,
I'm just going to add a block here.
So I'm actually going to make a list.
Let's say
objects is equal to Asterix Floor.
Now, if you ever seen like kind of dot,
dot, dot in JavaScript,
that's what this does in Python.
It just essentially breaks this floor
into all its individual
elements
and passes them inside of this list.
So imagine it
if me just writing this here,
that's what it's doing,
and then I'm going to pass another block.
And for this block,
I'm going to place this
at let's do zero.
And then for the why,
this is going to be the height
of the screen
minus the block size times two.
Now the reason I am multiplying
this by two is so that I get it a bit
higher on the screen
so that we can kind of run into it
horizontally.
And I'm going to pass my block size.
So just see, now I want to go
and rather than drawing my floor,
I want to pass objects
and same here
with handle move on to pass objects.
So let me run this.
So now you can see that
I have that block there right
now. Notice that when I hit the block,
I kind of go to the top of it.
And the reason I go to
the top of the block
is because right now
I'm only handling my vertical collision.
So when I hit the block,
I a little bit of gravity
because remember,
there's always some gravity on me
when I'm on the floor.
And so it thinks that
I've hit the top of the block,
so it spawns me on the top, the block.
So we need to make it now
so that when you hit the block
in the horizontal direction,
it kind of pops you off of it
so that it doesn't think you're
hitting the top of the block
or the bottom of the block, alternatively,
which you'll see in a second.
And in fact,
let me add one more block to show you.
Hitting our head on the block.
So let's add another block.
Let's make this at
same block size multiplied by.
And then for the heights, it's
two times four.
Okay, now we have another block.
Let's see where this guy is.
Now I can show you that
I can hit my head on the block. Right.
And I can't kind of go above it.
Okay, anyways, we have that.
Let's do our horizontal collision.
So the horizontal collision
is a bit weird to implement.
The idea behind this is that since
we're using our Sprite Collide mask,
we want to make sure that if we collide
with a block horizontally,
we move ourselves off of that block
so that it doesn't think
that we're colliding with it
in the vertical direction.
Now, you just saw that happen.
We hit the block.
It thought that we were hitting it
like the top of the block.
So it put us on the top of the block
because that's what this line does right
here.
So in our horizontal collision,
we essentially need to check, okay,
by moving in this direction,
are you going to hit the block?
If you are going to hit the block,
we want to prevent you
from moving in that direction
so that you don't
hit it, collide with it,
and then we like spawn to the top of it.
So let me write it
and I'll explain to you how it works.
But it's just very important that we check
the horizontal collision first.
Then once we check that,
we check the vertical collision
because we only want to check
vertical collision
if we are not colliding with a block
horizontally
or if we haven't already handled
or if we have already handled
the horizontal collision.
Again, the idea is
we don't want to be thinking that we're
hitting the block on the top when really
we hit it on the left or the right side.
So we've got to check that first.
So I'm going to make a function
you say define collide mean it's a player
objects a displacement X like that.
Now I'm going to say player dot move
and I'm going to move my player
in the displacement
X direction and zero in the Y direction.
The reason I'm doing this is
I want to check
if with the current velocity
that my player has, if
now the reason I'm doing this is
I want to check
if my player were to move to the right
or if they were to move to the left,
would they hit a block? That's that's
what I'm
checking essentially
by moving the player preemptively.
So now what I need to do
is say player to update.
Now the reason I need to call the update
and let's go here to update
is because I need to update the rectangle
in the mask before I check for collision.
So again, what I'm doing is I'm
preemptively moving my player
to where they would be moving
if they're going left or right.
I'm updating their mask
and their rectangle and then I'm going
to say for object
in objects, if pie game
dot, sprite dot collide mask
and then I'm passing player and my object.
So this is why I needed to update my mask
in my rectangle.
So I move my player,
I update it and then using that updated
mask, I check what I be colliding
with an object.
Now I'm going to say collided
object is equal to none.
I've got to spell colliding correctly.
If I am, then I'm going to say collided
and this is just going to be object
is equal object.
Then I'm going to break.
Okay, then I'm going to say, player,
don't move
and I'm going to move them back
and then I'm going to say player
dot update.
Okay.
And then I'm going to return the collided
object.
Okay.
So what I'm doing right, I'm
moving my player,
I'm updating the mask, I'm checking
if they would with something.
If they were to move in that direction,
then if they did.
Okay, I get that collide object.
It doesn't matter if they do
or they don't.
After I check this collision,
I have to move them back
to where they originally were.
Stuff to reverse the movement
and then update the mask again.
Then I return collide object.
Okay then moving checking
if we had anything either way.
Moving back to where we were before.
This is preemptively checking
before we allow them to move into a block.
All right.
Now what we need to do, use this function
R to allow us
to move left or right or to disallow us
from moving left or right.
So I'm going to say collide,
underscore left is equal to collide
player objects and then negative player.
Well, then I'm going to say collide
underscore right
is equal to collide player
objects and then player
and then I'm going to say
and not collide left
and not collide right again.
What we're doing here is we're checking
if we should be able to move left
or if we should be able to move right
based on our current position.
That's
why I make that preemptive movement.
And then here
I only let you make the movement
if that movement does not cause you
moving into a block or colliding with one,
now that we have that,
that should actually handle
our horizontal collision,
that's actually all we need.
All right.
So let me run this code
and let's see some here.
Okay. Obviously, that's still working.
And you can see that
I can't go through the block now.
Let's go here.
And actually, I'm
getting a bit of a bug on the right side.
Okay.
So that time it worked,
but it's a little bit glitchy
and I have a feeling
it has to do with the animation count
of me running because it's only some times
when I'm running and I hit the block
that it spawns me up here.
So I'm just going to do
another little hack here
and I'm just going to multiply
this by two.
Both of them here.
The reason for this being
that I'll just make it
so there's a little bit of space
between the block and that way.
Me changing
the sprite isn't going to affect.
I collide with the object or not,
because remember the sprites
kind of shift to the left
or to the right a little bit.
So just by adding this multiplied by two,
it should make it so that I'm never going
to be colliding left or right.
It will make it. There's a bit of space.
See how there's a bit of space
between the block now.
But that's okay because now
I'm never going to have that collision bug
where it's going to spawn me to the top.
And really
you could just add one or two pixels,
but you can see that
that kind of fixed it right there.
Okay.
So now we have collision with blocks,
we have a scrolling background,
we have double jumping.
I think that the last thing
that we need to add
here is the fire thing, right?
Kind of got trap or you hit it
and you kind of flash
and then once we've done
that, we'll pretty much be done.
The tutorial.
All right, so let's write our class
for representing our fire.
So I'm going to say class fire.
This is going to inherit
from object as well.
And this is going to be animated.
We're going to have animated fire.
So this will take a bit more work,
but I think it'll be worth it.
It looks pretty cool on the screen.
So I'm going to take X, Y width and height
and then I'm going to call
my super initialize.
So super
underscore, underscore net
self x, y, width and height.
Okay.
And then for the name of this,
I'm actually going to call it fire.
Remember that we can pass a name.
The reason I'm adding a name to the object
so that I can determine
when I collide with the object.
If it's fire and if it's fire,
then I want to do something right.
Okay.
So for self fire,
I'm going to use our load
sprite sheets function for directory one.
This is going to be traps and for
directory two, this is going to be fire.
Now if we go here to traps,
you can see that
fire is one of our traps
we have hit off on.
Okay.
Now there's also a bunch of other traps,
right?
So you can
you can pick a different trap if you want.
You could pass this blink one or whatever.
The thing with these ones
is that they have some more animations.
So there's a bit more logic
you need to handle for them.
So that's why I'm going with fire,
because it's a pretty simple one to do
now up here for fire.
I'm again going to have my animation
delay, so let's make that equal three
and now let's specify our image.
So Let's say ourself
that image is going to be self.
The fire off.
We're going to start with it off
and then zero.
Okay, then I'm going to say self
mask is equal to pi game
masked from surface self-taught
image like that.
Okay then I need to set an animation.
So I'm going to say
my animation underscore
count is equal to zero
just like we did for our player.
And I need to set myself
dot animation underscore
which for now is going to be equal to off.
Okay,
now I'm going to make a few functions.
My first function is going to be on
my first method and I can say
self-taught animation name is equal to.
And if we look at fire
we see we have hit off
on, we're not going to use hit,
we're just going to use off and on.
Okay.
Now we're going to have off
self self-taught animation
name is equal to off.
Okay and then we'll
our loop we'll say define loop self.
And inside of our loop
we're going to do a very similar thing
to what we did
inside of our player loop in fact.
So somewhere that I can copy
pretty much all of this right here.
So let's copy all that
and let's paste that.
Yeah.
Now for update rather than actually
just calling it update method, we'll
just copy the stuff from the update method
here and just paste it down.
Okay.
And rather than self that sprite,
we're going to change this to image.
And I actually think that once
we remove the direction here,
this is all that we need for our.
All right,
so now we just need to make a few changes.
We're going to get rid of this sprite
sheet name and rather than Sprite sheet
name, we're going to say
it's self dot animation name.
And now we should actually be good
to just use this.
So let me space this out a bit.
We get our sprites, okay?
This is it going to be self.
That's sprites.
No it's going to be self. That's right.
It's going to be self. Doubt fire.
Which is this.
Okay.
Really, I should call this something else,
but fire is going to represent
all of our fire images.
Okay, so I'm using this
to get my different animations.
I'm getting the animation name that I'm
currently playing, either on or off.
And then I'm saying my sprite index
is equal to self done animation count
divided by the self.
That animation delay mod the amount
of sprites, same as what we have before.
My image is equal
to sprites at sprite index
and then I increment the animation count,
update my rectangle and update my mask,
which is important for the collision.
And I'm good.
Now last thing I want to do here is
I want to just check
if my self-taught animation
count is greater than if this divided
by myself, that animation
delay is greater than the line of sprites.
Now the reason I want to
do this is so that my animation count
doesn't get too large.
Now you'll notice in my player class
I actually didn't do this.
Now that was intentional
because if you do this,
then it kind of messes up
how the double works.
You can do it if you want, but you'll see
that it kind of messes with things.
And with our player,
we're constantly resetting
the animation count when we jump
or when we go left or when we go right.
So that value doesn't
really get too large.
But here for our fire, since it's just
static, like it's just sitting forever,
what will happen is the animation count
if we never change it back to zero,
we'll get to an extremely large number
which can kind of lag our program.
So what I want to do
is just make it smaller, right?
So if it goes beyond
what the actual animation,
what do you call it,
this is the line of the Sprite start.
Then I want to set this to zero.
It's important
I divide it by the animation
delay, though,
because if I'm dividing it here,
I need to divide it here before
I set it back to zero.
Okay, so now we have fire
and that's actually all we need for fire.
So now we just need to add it
to our objects.
So let's create it. Let's say
fire.
So you go to fire and what do we need
to pass for fire in x, y, width and height
so we can pick where we want to put this?
Where do I want to put my x and Y?
Okay,
for now let's go hundred and let's go.
Height minus the block size.
And then I don't know
how tall my fire's going to be.
I've got to see how big
I want to make this.
Let's make it say 60
and then we'll go 30 to 64 here.
Okay. So if we look at fire, it's quick.
We have a look here and go to off example
or on
the size of this is 32 by 64.
Okay, that's what the size is
and you need to pass that correctly
to the fire class, otherwise
it won't load the image properly.
So we take our height minus our block
size, -64,
which will put us on top of a block.
Now I will put this at.
Yeah, 100 is fine
for now for the X and yeah.
32 width, 60 for height.
There we go. We have our fire now.
I was going
say fired up on I'm just going to turn it
on, we'll just leave it on forever.
You can turn off programmatically
if you want.
And then inside of objects,
all this place, my fire.
Now that I've done that.
It should just show up on the screen
when I run my car.
So I got an issue.
Let's see what the bug is here.
Of course,
the output is not showing up correctly.
This is an it takes from 5 to 6 plus positional arguments which seven were given.
Okay,
I see the issue here.
Let's go back to our fire.
And we don't want to pass self.
Let's remove self.
Okay, let's run this
list index out of range
so that fire off zero.
Hmm. Okay.
I'm wondering why that's
giving us an issue we have off here.
So that should have been.
Okay, so let's go here and let's print
self-taught fire
and let's see why it's giving us this
this bug here.
All right.
So I have determined the issue,
and the issue is
that I passed the incorrect size here.
It's actually 16 by 32.
So it's passing too large of a size.
And that's why it wasn't giving us
the correct number images.
So let's change this now and run.
And now we should be okay.
And there we go. Now we have fire.
But however it is off now
the reason it's off is because we didn't
call the loop method on fire.
So let's fix that
and also get rid of the print statement
that I put here that I don't need anymore.
Okay, so let's go
down to Main
and where we have player out loop.
Let's call fire
dot loop and is asking for the piece.
I don't know if I took that in my loop
here.
No, I don't need the props for that.
So let's get rid of that.
Okay. Now let's call it
and it should start
being on fire
object has not shoot sprites.
Okay, let's go fix that error.
My apologies.
Fire.
We have Sprite somewhere here
that we don't want self.
That Sprite is going
be self thought image and self-taught
image. All right, start with that.
Let's run it now. And there we go.
We now have a moving fire.
And notice that I can kind of be
on top of the fire, right?
So I can collide with it.
And it's like pixel perfect collision
pretty much when I'm hitting it.
So now the last thing we need
is to just make it
so we go into that kind of hit state.
When we do hit the fire,
that's actually pretty easy to do.
We just need to add a kind of state
to our player to know if we're hit or not.
So we're going to say self-deport.
Hit is equal to false.
We also want to hit counts
because we're going to only be flashing
for a certain amount of time.
Then we're going to have a method here
to fine hit
self.
Self to hit equals true
in self that hit count
is equal to zero.
Then we're going to go in loop
and before our update sprite, we're
going to say if self-taught hit,
then self-taught hit count
plus equals one.
And then we're going to say
if self-taught hit count
is greater then
and we can just pick some value.
But let's say f-pace multiplied by two,
which is going to be 2 seconds,
then the self taught hit
is equal to false.
Then we go here into our update sprite
and we say actually at the
top here, if self-doubt hits,
it's important
you put this at the top, by the way.
So I'm actually buddy here.
Then we are going to say the sprite sheet
is equal to hit.
Great.
Then we want to now determine
if we actually got hit.
So we do that from our collision functions
which are going to be here.
All right.
So we have collide left.
We have collide, right.
And we're going to have
vertical
collide.
Now, what we're going to do
is we're essentially going to loop through
all of these objects
and we're going to see if we hit fire.
Now, the way we'll know if we hit
fire is by looking at all
the objects that were returned here.
And it will tell us, well,
if we hit fire or not.
Right. Because we can
look at the name of the object.
And if the name of the object is fire,
then we know we have fire.
So I'm going to say
to check is equal to
collide left, collide right
and asterisks vertical collide.
Now I realized that inside of here
I only returned one object, whereas
inside of here I returned all the objects
I was colliding with vertically.
Really, we should probably be returning
all of them from here as well,
but I think this is still going to work.
So we'll just leave it
how it is for right now.
So I to say, for object
in to underscore check
these are all the objects
we collided with.
Remember I'm going to say
if to underscore, check and to underscore
check dot name is equal to fire
then player dot hit
is able to trip.
Okay that is all we need.
And actually
I'm going to say player to hits
I want to call the method
I don't want to set it equal to true.
So what we're doing here
is looking through all the objects
we collide with, if any of them are fire,
then we will put hit on the player.
The reason I'm doing this first,
if to check, is
because these could be none, right?
We could have no objects we collide with.
So I need to make sure I handle that case
before I try to access name on an object
that isn't defined.
All right,
let's run the code and let's see.
And player has no object, no attribute hit
count.
Okay, so let's go to player
and let's go to hit count
and let's make that equal to zero.
I guess I forgot to assign that.
All right, let's try this.
Now, list object has no attribute name.
Okay, interesting.
Let's see here.
Okay.
All right, so I'm using to check
when I need to be checking object.
So let's fix that.
And the code
blue object is not callable.
Okay, player dot hit.
Aha. So let's call this make hit.
It's because I have an attribute
with the same name as my method.
So it's accessing the attribute
when it should be accessing the method.
So I'm just going to say
make underscore hit.
And now that should
fix the problem for us.
Run the code and there we go.
Now it looks like
I'm always being hit right now.
That, of course, is a bug.
So hit is equal to false.
Let's let's check our hit count.
It's because if self-doubt
hits off the hit count plus, it goes one
if self the hit count is greater
than self-tan equals false.
Maybe we need to reset our hit
count as well.
Okay.
And there's probably a bug
here.
Let's scroll down,
keep scrolling with our
so we have to check if okay
you would be a name equals
it goes fire player don't make hit
okay I'm
not sure what the bug is.
Let me run this again.
And yeah, it seems like
we start out in the hit state,
so maybe it's an issue in here.
Let's have a look here. If self-taught hit
spreadsheet equals hit.
But we are we hit right away for some
reason it's making us hit immediately.
Okay. Let me have a look here. Yes.
And I'll be right back.
All right. So I've realized
I made a silly mistake here.
I actually have this collided
objects append outside of this
if statement and that was causing
all kinds of bugs and issues for me.
I think I was doing some print debugging,
so let me get rid of that here.
Anyways, I just moved it back now.
So that is in the correct location.
So now if I rerun this
now we should see that
when I hit the fire
it puts me into kind of this hit
state last 2 seconds and then it ends.
All right. So that's it, guys.
I think that's pretty much going
to wrap up this video.
This showed you
how to create a platformer,
how to do animations, how to be sprites,
how to do a scrolling background.
Obviously, there is a ton of stuff
that could be added to this game,
but I really want to leave that to you.
Obviously, I could spend hours,
days, months working on a game like this,
but I think this is a solid enough base
to really give you guys
a good foundation to go out there
and create something pretty cool.
Obviously There's all kinds of assets
that I would leave in the GitHub
that you can use.
I have all kinds of other PI game
tutorials that you may want to reference.
If you want to learn
about Menu's sound effects
points,
scoring, all of that kind of stuff.
You guys go
my channel search pie game tutorial.
You will see a bunch of them.
Those will show you how to do a
ton of other things that you know
you may want to add to this game.
So I hope you enjoyed this.
This was a ton of work.
As always,
the code will be in the description
if you did enjoy make,
surely they like subscribe to the channel.
Consider supporting me by purchasing
something like programing expert
and I hope to see
you in another YouTube video.